I'm Danica Patrick and I'm pretty
intense it's a simple little tool RAIM
and so this just offers a space to pause
so for field before we react what do we
take time and you rain rain is first
recognize mm-hmm
a is acknowledge you were sort of
talking about this earlier yeah so so
recognize what is it that I'm feeling
feeling something about am I feeling
excited am I feeling triggered in my
feelings scared
am I not wanting to open up in that
vulnerable space so we recognize it yeah
then we acknowledge it yeah so okay all
right that's what that is then I is
investigate so how does that feel for me
and what's coming up is there old belief
systems coming in or there old stories
wrapped around it and n is one of my
favorites and it's non personal
everybody dies I mean it's like that's
pretty like the barometer on how far
you've got in this growth game is how
can how can you can you operate where
you don't take things personally because
then it means that you recognize that
their actions say more about the way
they feel about themselves and about you
and it is yeah that's that this have fun
isn't it yeah taking things personally
it's just like normal and when I learned
that simple tool it created the space
for me to just pause to just stop mm-hmm
and breathe and I literally will reign
through through the process and it
actually goes pretty quick now so like
you said you we learn new ways new tools
to move through so so we're just growing
from what once did service at times for
protection and and expansion but there's
new levels of it as we're becoming
bringing more consciousness in and we're
opening more in relationships in our
lives
and doing that how do how do we hold
that space and do it from our heart and
not from our head so the rain for me
gets me out of my head it gets me into
my heart space so I can actually feel
and speak from that place and whether
it's a difficult conversation or it's a
conversation just full of love and joy
it still is something that just keeps it
in truth another word of your yeah one
of your words in the air truth which is
a big one of many good ones yeah
[Music]